hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the question that
we're going to be positive is this
versus does that mean that it's sort of
like me draw a line and say either up
here or you have justice and the two
don't like intrude into each other's
domains or does justice come in to some
extent into a care perspective and this
care coming in to some extent into a
justice perspective this doesn't mean
that they're like p.m. fuse together
exactly the same thing but do they
modify each other so here's one of the
greatest let's create employment
something else Friedman said justice is
relevant to carry at least three
different lives so this would be where
justice goes in here what would those
ways okay so one of these is this issue
of giver and the
whenever you have a relationship there's
always the possibility of imbalance of
what people are putting into the
relationship you guys are all familiar
that's right from friendships from
professional relationships that you had
probably from some family things as well
think about for example a couple where
will they get their sort of
stereotypical thing the woman does all
of the things within the home decorates
it make sure that it's nice living space
ranges everything takes care of all that
sort of stuff the guy goes out works
comes home puts his feet up and watches
TV what do you think of these new
decorations she's doing stuff for him he
is a receiver in that case she makes him
great meals he appreciates the meals did
you make me more of this stuff really
like this meatloaf how about we have
that five nights a week okay that sounds
good you know whatever makes you happy
now is he giving anything in return well
maybe he's paying for things that's not
really the same thing is it it's not the
same thing is that the tension or
affection so maybe you know after a
while she gets get sick of it she says
you never listen to me that's a common
complaint made in relationships both
weights by the way what is somebody
complaining about that case you're not
actually giving me attention which is a
good within a relationship it's not a
monitor good but it's a very important
emotional isn't it you know it's like we
may not listen to the difference between
the adhan somebody actually
to you kind of irritates you in somebody
doesn't listen right I feel like what's
the point so that can be understood as
an imbalance of justice if I give
attention to you let's say it's a
friendship if I listen to your BS and
you're venting and your nonsense
shouldn't you have to listen to mine
isn't that fair that's that's a justice
perspective right but it's coming into a
relationship so that's one way in which
it's important like she says quite often
women serve man's physical and
psychological needs and wants rather
than the other way around it's women who
feed men's egos and whether to tens
man's needs unless this inequitable if
you talk about inequity or equal justice
an equitable state of affairs is
remedied over time then women's acts of
caring get turned into what masochism
whats masses we have you get a familiar
with that somebody's a masochist was
anything
they've it had intro to cite you can
take that shape sometimes self self
harming oftentimes man Lucas are willing
to let other people hurt them because
they get something out of it and
sometimes they come to desire that
there's actually an old joke you're
making what did what is a masochist say
hurt me hurt me and what does it say to
say to the masochist no because the save
us enjoy is messing with other people
and usually a sadist would want to
inflict harm on other people but the
masochist actually wants the harms of
the same says screw you I'm not going to
happen I'm going to frustrate you but
you know the relationships can become
masochistic very often abusive
relationships have an element of this
that's why it's hard to get out of
abusive relationships because it becomes
a cycle and that's why people who've
been abused often end up in New abusive
relationships because it takes down this
character that's where care could go
wrong and justice needs to come in to
modify care another probably is let's
call it vulnerable
within relationships you are more
vulnerable to people who you care about
and care for them to any stranger on the
street right I mean you care what people
who you're a close to think of more than
you care about people you don't know oh
right even with Facebook and likes and
you know things like that mean comments
most people care more about what their
frequent interactors think than Joe
Schmo over here it doesn't care for that
doesn't know him so like she points out
personal relationships create special
vulnerabilities to harmons someone I
care about who supposedly cares what
harms me justice once again justice
comes in says that arm should be right a
care perspective doesn't get you care by
itself just says keep on caring justice
says don't stop caring that point and
demand that thing's be set right before
you start caring again because otherwise
you're still born more vulnerable than
that person hurting she also said
something really interesting when I when
I was first reading this I didn't catch
that I I was thinking well okay I care
for somebody else that makes me a belong
now she actually says the fact that
someone cares for me does not give him
or her license to exploit and oppressed
me so it's not just about the person
who's caring getting getting screwed
over by somebody who's being mean to
them taking advantage of their
vulnerabilities they're giving nature
than nurturing being caring also doesn't
give you a license to be abusive to
other people and you see this quite
often in relationships where somebody is
is good to a person in one way and then
bad them in another way and then when
they get their complaints quit doing
that to me they say yeah but I'm doing
this for you too don't you like when I
do this so rock on Tonya saying want to
call it Ross tom is saying that's a case
where justice should intervene the third
thing is relationships
relationships have a lot of what should
we call them not not necessarily
temptations but it's possible for
injustice to take place very easily
within the context of relationships
let's call these will say problematic
think about a family situation how many
of you have brothers and sisters or i
should say hey brother grace the
strictest well you have brothers and
sisters right the UN mr. primont so
nearly all of it is your are your
siblings into exactly the same things as
you do they need the day the same needs
the same wats the same desires as you do
now imagine that your your parents and
your you're really interested in helping
everybody your parents may be like this
Romania but just imagine that the army
everybody should flourish everybody
should be doing well we should try to
satisfy everybody's desires at least
insofar as they're good for them you
know will they give you the same things
that give your siblings yes or no right
now
because you're different and you need
different things yeah do you ever feel
like you maybe got the better end of the
deal or your sibling got the better end
of the deal you know I mean who usually
gets the most attention is that the kid
who is focused quietly doing well
there's a screw screw up right why
because the screw kit actually needs
more attention is that fair really who
should be getting more attention it
should be the one who's they actually
not screwing up right care gives care
has a tendency to lead to getting more
and more attention that way that can
lead to some imbalances some some lakhs
of fairness which justice would be
happen to think that all of mine to
remedy she you know says should mom and
dad you of their son Jim privileges are
not willing to give the daughter sue
should mr. and mrs. Jones paper Grandpa
Jones much-needed vacation or daughter
Beth summer camps you know this is a
these are the sort of issues that people
face all the time doesn't necessarily
even have to be that who shouldn't have
the second jump and who should stay home
to you know keep the family going on who
should have to go to work who should get
to know to school these are all really
vital questions aren't they and the
worse the economy gets the more pressing
these sort of things again I think when
you guys are having kids because the
economy doesn't show any sign of like
you know radically restructuring itself
you guys are going to be faced with
these kind of dilemmas quite bit and so
caring could actually lead to one child
getting way more time attention
resources then justice would say that
they deserve so justice would have to
come into
does it work the other way around does
caring have anything to contribute to
justice she gives some examples your
finger when we don't punish adolescents
he has the same as adults we do
sometimes punish them as adults of what
it does particularly heinous what's
going on why are we why are we not
punishing even sometimes a 16 year old
who may be a terrible person he has an
adult yeah cuz I don't we consider their
end up to be like mentally fully
different enough to make the right
decision that's one element of it now
notice you know when it comes to impulse
control what are your brains actually
fully developed are you exactly why not
that's what the researchers are saying
now that you don't have the same impulse
control at 24 that idea at 43 there's
exceptions of course some people are
outliers but it takes some time so I
mean if that's the reasoning maybe we
should actually try 21 year olds
different 40 girls that's part of it do
we also feel a sense of compassion or
pity or something like that sympathy
that would be that'll be caring
intruding into justice and perhaps I
mean what do you guys think should
should that be the case should we have
that option judges or should we just say
16 year olds you're basically the same
as that 18 year old let's try to the
same no another example is more common
mean look at sentenced at age 16 I'm
guessing right we sometimes give people
another chance because it would be too
cruel to ruin their lives on a common
single mistake when you guys address
that application assignment with the
student who cheated some of you came up
with the option well the professor auto
like sit down with her and actually
discuss it with her and say what's up
with you why are you doing this you
gotta knock this stuff wha I'm not going
to like turn you into the Dean but I am
going to make you retake the test or
something like that that would that
would in fact be a caring and wouldn't
that it would be showing kind of empathy
and care for the well-being of that
student when justice would say and some
of you said no the student aw be
punished right you were taking a justice
perspective some of you did it from
utilitarian perspective
like look at all the schools have
trouble with with you know grades
cheating and all that stuff we got to
make an example this one well that would
be the justice perspective when we're
saying now we're not the ruin this
person is why for career or academic
record for it doesn't get caught later
and it goes into transferred right for
this one case that's care going into
justice here's another example I like
particularly we occasionally give people
more than their fair share because why
we want to cheer them up now if does
justice ever tell you that you ought to
cheer somebody up that they're deserving
and you cheering them up no it's because
you actually feel affection for them you
like them I don't do you think that's a
good thing that every once in a while we
would give people more than their fair
share because we want to cheer them up
attention stuff that we have available
to us I think that's pretty important
don't you so that would be another way
in which caring and can actually come in
and fit in with with justice so they
asked one important set of criticisms
and how those can be